Welcome,
welcome,
welcome.
The Tuesday episode of the podcast.
This is the experience that you need.
You may hear other people talking about
current events,
uh,
giving their opinions on things,
but let me tell you,
there is no other place on the Internet
with the cutting edge and formed
opinions,
correct opinion like here on the
podcast,
Tuesdays edition.
So welcome one and all to the current
events experience.
Oh,
that's the right one.
There you go.
Today's episode is sponsored by better
help
and just remind you guys,
you all better hurry on down to tell you
fresh because we're having a crazy sale.
We have completely lost our minds.
End of season,
sale,
50 thing,
50 percent off long sleeves.
Hoodies,
jackets,
trinkets,
beanies,
hats.
Y'all better head on down to [inaudible]
dot com slash collection slash sale.
Wow.
Some of these aren't even sold out,
so there is serious urgency here,
right?
This is serious.
Let's just get.
Let's just get right into it.
We have the best opinions here at the
podcast.
You're going to find out.
That's what I'm talking about actually
for the rest of the month.
We have gas book them,
book the book,
so the idea was that we're gonna deliver
to you guys a Tuesday episode with
current events and cutting edge.
Well thought out,
well informed opinions that are correct
every time they're expressed,
and if you disagree,
it may be time to switch the channel
because these are correct opinions.
Go for the day.
Let's start from the top.
Baby.
You know I was told I was joking with
Isla.
Yeah,
just a week ago.
I said,
you know what is a funny joke maybe to
tweet Isla with back to school,
a lar backpack.
I was like,
Hey,
get 50 percent off your Kevlar backpacks
back to school sale.
And he was like,
tasteless.
Don't tweet it.
I thought it was probably too far.
I was like,
okay,
maybe you're right.
Maybe I'm just twisted sick individual.
Guess what we saw were what?
What?
What News station was this on?
Here?
Let me pop this up.
Fox News,
Fox business,
one of those fucking business.
Are we separating?
So there's different St.
Yeah,
that's pretty much the same thing.
Well,
anyway,
on Fox News,
this is.
There's so many layers of greatness to
this.
This is the good for the day.
By the way,
if you guys,
we need to regimen it out.
You Go.
So
selling bulletproof vest,
bulletproof backpack while playing
bulletproof.
The song sponsored by Chrysler
was tasteless.
Now we're just going to make a little
joke and here they're
selling it on the news sponsored by
Chrysler.
You know,
it's like damn.
It's like the car company.
Yeah,
it's all sponsored by Chrysler school
shootings sponsored by Chrysler here.
Meeting this morning.
Mc Armor is the company behind high end.
Bulletproof backpacks and clothing that
are revamping.
Just shoot her point blank.
That'll,
that'll,
that'll teach the kids how to,
uh,
make sure their backpacks works.
I remember kids,
if you want to ensure that your backpack
isn't a bulletproof,
bring a gun to school and shoot your
friend.
Point blank is this,
this is anticipated to reach more than
$5,000,000,000
in the next seven years.
That would be the,
as a school shooting.
Oh,
they really projecting a lot by 20,
25.
You cannot project out seven years and
seven years.
I'm projected to be the president.
See if that happens.
So I thought this was just a goof.
I thought this was a total blast.
So next time you guys go to the Chrysler
dealership,
remember school shootings saying,
have a backpack with your new Chrysler.
Get up Kevlar backpack.
How excuses not going to do.
And that's just like,
well imagine there's like an active
shooter.
You're like,
Whoa,
your backpack around the front.
I'm just trying to like dodged the
bullet and shit.
Brought to you by Chrysler.
So who's tasteless now about my ideas
now too.
It kind of a forward thinker,
aren't they?
See I did it as a joke,
but these guys are serious as as a I
want to say schools,
the traditional saying is as serious as
a heart attack and I want to revise it
to as serious as a school shooting for
as much extra tastelessness as possible.
Now,
Isla,
you've heard the saying,
they're taking our jobs.
Robots are taking our jobs.
I've expressed concern on this very
podcast than automation are taking our
jobs.
Now.
This video is going to haunt you.
It is going to really concern you and
hopefully everyone watching at home.
This is not to be taken lightly.
Okay.
What we have here is a golfing robot.
If they can golf better than us,
then we are really.
Fuck.
Look at this Golfer
yesterday.
A robot taking a swipe at this robot
called Hail.
You know it's true.
You know,
it's real positive.
Look at these guys jumping and cheering
for their heralding the end and 10
years.
They're not going to be golfers anymore.
She's going to a bunch of robots on the
field.
Hitting balls,
golf,
robotic football,
basketball.
She's gonna.
Be Robot.
That is actually pretty cool though.
You won't see that again.
Yellow.
Yeah.
Really cool.
Down
robot will take it a swipe.
It kind of looks like the guy that would
play golf or something.
Insane.
Shot robot.
Dude.
His name is eldrich.
Hold on one second.
Value your jobs.
They're coming for all of them.
A Post Malone,
our dear friend.
I don't know if you guys follow this has
just happened this morning.
Um,
well last night he won song of the year
vms.
Very proud of him.
Yeah,
he won it for Rockstar and just I just,
I want to congratulate him.
I want to say I love him.
He's a sweet,
dear,
great guy.
He deserves it and it's insane to see
what he's accomplished since we met him.
I mean even just this year,
we probably met him like two years ago
now,
but like this year alone,
since his new album came out,
it was crazy.
Damn.
And it's easy to forget what is.
He's 23 years old.
Okay.
That should make everybody at home
depressing.
That depresses the hell out of me.
But I was 23 years old.
I was probably playing world of warcraft
and it in a disgusting dormitory room
with like leftover Burrito's.
I mean I was going nowhere fast.
Pretty incredible.
What a 23 year old can accomplish.
So love and pride for him.
Let's watch his acceptance speech.
Here you go.
Twenty one savage,
right?
I just want it,
you know,
you go to bed and you dream about maybe
winning and then whenever you get up
here you don't remember what the hell to
say because you wrote it on.
But you know,
thank you so much everybody that was,
he's not that tall.
He's a tall guy,
but he's not that tall.
Why y'all making them laugh like he's
five,
two for Christ's sake.
I mean the guy,
it's his big moment.
Why are you making them punch over like
that?
That's a good point though.
Damn the song.
Um,
thank you everybody for listening.
It's funny.
We know a lot of them.
Honestly,
in 100 million years I would never
expect to do this ever.
So this is sick and uh,
thank you so much.
Yeah.
Oh,
21 post.
Close the mic on that.
Thank you to east Atlanta.
Lower than like more
lower the mic.
They found like a button.
Like can we lower the mic on savage by
the way?
I have.
We were at his birthday party and I was
like,
man,
I want to get them a sixth birthday gift
because he's like such a good friend.
He bought you a really beautiful gift on
your birthday.
He got isla,
like this limited edition,
Supreme Fender Strat Guitar.
There's only like 30 of them in the
world.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't have anything that is so
valuable.
Other than that I didn't know what to
do.
I didn't take it on the wall,
but he just shows up.
He shows up like a couple hours after he
shows up,
some dude shows up with a guitar.
Yeah.
And it was like this incredible fender
strap,
supreme limited edition.
And I was like,
oh wow.
Really Cool Guitar.
Like I didn't even understand that he
was giving it to you.
I thought the guy just delivered it to
post and then he left.
I was like,
Oh,
we forgot his guitar.
And he was like,
it's for me.
No,
I didn't get that.
But anyway,
I was like,
Damn,
how the fuck do we top that?
So well you can't.
So.
Well I can't really.
But I was like,
how I got to get them a really nice
gift.
So I got,
I went down,
he's a gun fanatic.
We've been to this gun store together
and I got them this cool little snippy.
I'm,
what'd you just link me,
Dan?
What I think is the guitar that you're
talking about.
Oh,
let's show it.
And we got pictures on deck,
did we?
We're so interactive.
We are.
So this is such an experience that we
can just talk about something and show
it to you at the same time.
Cutting edge technology here.
This is such an experience.
If only I could do it within.
Actually pretty incredible stuff here
folks,
Birdie,
incredible stuff here folks.
Okay.
I'm still,
I don't know.
How do you display it to you?
Do you frame it?
Because it also comes in a nice box.
Do you keep it in the box or not?
You take it out of the box.
I think you,
you.
I mean there's mounts for guitars.
I think kind of just like a wall piece.
I don't think you.
I think you just hang it.
But anyway,
I'm calling you.
His birthday isla was gone so I was
Kinda on my own by the way,
taking care of myself,
which is hard enough as it is.
And so I go to this gunshot.
I'm like,
what can I do?
What can I get posted?
So he had ordered this really cool glock
from them and I was like,
I want to get him something dope.
So I got him this little snipey cool ass
laser snipey they put on top of the
Glock,
right?
That the official name?
Or are you just calling it?
It's an APP.
It's called a snipey.
It's a.
it's a scope.
It's a sick ass scope by the way,
because you only see it if you look
through the snipey hole.
So if you got someone locked on,
they don't see the laser right here.
Like in the movies only you see it.
It's an Ip then.
Right.
And I got him like a thousand rounds.
I thought I was feeling pretty good.
I had like two ammo boxes,
a snipey,
a bunch of rounds and I was like,
no,
that's a thoughtful gift.
Personal.
It's pretty weird to show up into a
party where it was a big party and I
felt a little bit strange showing up
with Ammo at that gun store.
I was like,
are you sure this is okay?
It's funny.
I actually went in there to buy him a
weapon.
I was like,
I'm going to buy him a gun.
They're like,
you can't like what?
What are you fucking stupid?
You can't buy him a gun and bring it to
a party.
I was like,
Oh,
I guess that does make sense.
I guess that's probably a good thing.
I guess that's the one thing you can do
in America.
I was like,
that's probably.
Yeah,
that's probably a good thing.
It's funny.
On one hand I'm like,
here on the show being like gun control,
I'm like,
can I buy a weapon?
And then on the same day give it to
somebody else.
They're like,
no,
dude,
I guess that makes sense.
Anyway,
I bought a bunch of Ammo,
thousand rounds of snipey.
I probably spent like $1,500.
Pretty good.
Yeah.
I was like,
Damn.
I hooked up my dude up and then I,
I,
he comes and I was like,
hey man,
check out.
But I got you.
And he was very gracious.
Isn't about post at all.
This is more a rant against 21 savage
because I have beef with that guy.
He doesn't know it,
so I mean pulse was very gracious,
very sweet as you know.
He's a perfect angel.
Probably the closest thing to a perfect
human being and then savage shows up and
he gives him,
I shit you not like five minutes later,
100,000
dollar watch.
I'm like,
okay,
Mr.
fucking hip hop you gotta show my broke
ass up.
You know,
what kind of watch was it?
Do you remember?
I Dunno it,
but it was like on the news and now
twitter news.
Where's my snipey and the that was
newsworthy and now I see Austin walking
around with his sick ass hundred
thousand dollar watch.
Don't see them walking around with this
snipey.
It's not about how much the gift cost,
it's about the gesture.
In this case it was most definitely
about.
Well he loved to watch.
He was a great watch.
He was a great gift.
I just honestly wish maybe you could
have waited and given it to him before
the party,
you know,
like maybe a different time.
So it was just kind of rude to me
personally.
And I do take it as a kind of a problem.
So if you see savage,
let him know that we do have beef.
Don't let him know everyone's going to
be.
Hmm.
No.
But anyway,
congratulations to post them.
And then this morning that happened last
night.
And this morning,
uh,
I see my brother in law who's like,
somehow like we got to hire my brother
research.
This guy is like in tune with the world.
He,
uh,
he sends me a TMZ article.
It's like post Malone's airplane is
stuck in the air.
The wheels blew out when they take off,
by the way,
what are the wheels just blow up when
you're taking off.
How's that a thing?
So he's circling around doing an,
about to do an emergency landing there
in the air,
doing circles,
trying to burn up fuel to reduce the
weight so they can,
you know,
land more safely.
Carry.
And so anyway,
he landed.
He is safe or vault.
Very happy about that.
We were watching live here in the
office.
Um,
he made this tweet.
I landed,
guys,
thank you for your prayers.
CanNot believe how many people wished
death on me.
Fuck you.
But not today.
I can't believe that.
When I read that,
I was like,
whoa.
I didn't see any.
I mean,
I wasn't looking well.
Yeah,
but I wasn't leaving.
But people are so insane.
Be like,
imagine he's on the airplane,
like super scared and he's reading shit.
Like I hope he crashes and dies.
I'm like,
what?
Y'All are fucking need Jesus.
I would never say that to anyone,
but if you said that to him,
you need Jesus.
Can you.
Can you diagnose that Ila,
why are people saying that to them?
Do they need Jesus or what are they
missing?
Um,
no.
They just knew their life.
Yeah.
So anyway,
love.
Congratulations.
Appreciations to post malone safe and
he's alive
and he's looking good.
Is looking good.
It's got all this suits lately.
Yeah,
I know.
It's crazy.
You look thin in that vma video.
Two.
Yeah,
I think also a lot of weight.
I think he's losing weight.
He's slamming his jam and he's a
Rockstar.
Loves us.
Now moving on to something more
interesting than that.
Somebody emailed me.
Oh,
uh,
over the past couple of days and email
that kind of stood out to me and sort of
shocked me.
He said to me,
Hey,
I've been listening a lot to your
conversation about wiping and anal,
you know,
cleanliness and hygiene,
and he says,
you know,
what I do is I near my asshole.
I was like,
Whoa,
there is a topical cream that you apply
to the hair and then you.
And then basically it burns it off and
you just wipe it clean.
So this guy was like,
I use sensitive Nair on my asshole rink
and I wiped the hair.
I was like,
whoa.
That is so insane and hilarious.
I think I have to try it.
I think you
shouldn't because this stuff is like,
you could burn your skin.
I actually,
I didn't know what it was.
I went on Amazon just to check the
reviews and like most of the reviews are
pictures of people got burned,
seen assholes.
No
assholes.
More resilient or less resilient really
because it touched his shit.
I think they would have let him know.
Well,
I think that's part of the charm is
that,
I mean,
first of all,
I'm in the pursuit of knowledge.
This is like forbidden fruit,
forbidden knowledge and Biblical and the
Biblical on emission.
It's more important.
It's not just a mission.
This is God's work.
Read the Messenger.
If you read the Bible,
the story of Adam and Eve,
the apple is the forbidden knowledge.
People don't always talk about how they
wiped their ass and cleaned their ass
and these important things that we need
to collectively share our knowledge.
So I think of myself as kind of a
trailblazer of a kind of a,
a Magellan,
Christopher Columbus.
I don't know.
I think he was someone who explored.
Okay,
I'm an explorer.
I'm kind of a Darwin,
if you will.
I'm a great thinker.
They said Isaac Newton,
Isaac Newton said of himself,
I'm not a giant.
I just stand on the shoulders of those
before me.
[inaudible].
That's what I'm.
How is that related?
Because I'm how to ask wiping giant.
I lent.
I stand on the shoulders of the wealth
of knowledge with those who've come
before me.
Nobody has dared and the history of
mankind as far as I can tell,
to collect this knowledge and to share
it with the world.
This is important stuff.
So I think the pursuit of the forbidden
fruit and the biblical tale of Adam and
Eve there is much the same.
And so I will near my asshole
and he burned.
Narrow is like a something you put
inside your asphalt really when you
like.
What is it?
Let's say you need to take a pill but
throw your right.
It's like medicine or would you call a
suppository?
Yeah.
So that's what that's called.
And they're.
Oh,
that's this show.
The first time you said that to me,
I was like,
what do you mean [inaudible]?
You're good.
That's almost a sign from God.
I mean,
he grows God's language,
right?
So narrow in a way was almost a destiny.
The destiny will use of nir was.
So you kind of supporting my,
my um.
Well I think for think this week I'm in
there,
my asshole for better or worse if it
burns,
if it cures.
I mean,
I have never had a wipe in recent memory
that wasn't Harry and I think that this
could be it.
Has the metamucil been helping you?
Love it.
It's not a cure all,
like a lot of people and asking for
updates on the metamucil,
this fiber supplement.
I haven't been taking it too because
it's also just fiber,
which should be good.
But like when I,
I didn't notice any difference in.
Yeah,
see the first time I took it,
I swear to God it was like Teflon Colon.
I just slid right out.
Yeah.
Um,
but for me it's not the end all
situation.
Like Chris had I,
I'm,
I have a hybrid situation.
I,
I'm using less baby wipes,
but I'm still ending what supposedly he
takes more because there's these huge
pills and they say you have to take like
a year of them and thinking,
whoa.
Yeah.
Well I'm curious,
what do you guys,
you know,
I,
I want not just the great thinkers who
join us here today.
I'm looking for the great thinkers out
there,
the great minds out there that have
interesting wiping techniques.
So actual dark web.
Yeah,
exactly.
So guys,
give us a ring today.
Eight.
Oh,
eight hot meme.
Um,
we're looking for great,
great thinkers.
Okay,
so give us a call at eight.
Oh,
eight hot meme.
And share your techniques.
I'm very curious to hear what you're
doing.
Okay.
Um,
with that being said,
we've got so many great videos come up.
We're going to take a quick break,
but coming up next,
do drinks his own.
Come in a video that's fully monetized.
The channel name is gay.
God beautiful.
And he is living up to that name.
He drinks his own.
Come maybe.
I don't know if I give you a reason to
close it,
but it's very funny.
Very.
So I don't think we'd want to miss this.
Would that being said,
my dudes.
Let's kick into a break.
We'll be right back.
Thank you.
To better help for sponsoring this
episode of the podcast.
I need some better help.
I'm anxious right now.
God seriously.
But this is one of these genius
services.
It's online counseling.
They've got fully licensed counselors
ready to consult with at any time you
get access to licensed,
trained,
fully accredited counselors and
therapists,
Lgbtq plus friendly.
Basically whoever you are,
what religion you are,
couples,
anything.
Boom,
they've got you covered with fully
trained therapists to talk to you.
All you have to do is go to better
help.com/h
three,
fill out a brief questionnaire about
what's going on with you and they match
you up with a counselor who is a perfect
match for you and you can start
counseling pretty much right away after
they hook you up with a counselor that's
affordable.
Therapy is expensive,
which is kind of such bs because
everybody
needs help.
In fact,
you might even say poor people are the
ones that have more shit to deal with
because everybody needs money,
but guess what?
It's way cheaper than in person
counseling.
There's therapists costs like $300 an
hour,
but okay,
I'll share.
I'll spend half of my paycheck to talk
to,
but here's the thing.
Pricing is between 35 to $65 a week for
unlimited counseling.
Meaning you are connected with a
counselor the entire time via your phone
or a computer.
You can schedule a video phone or tech
sessions when necessary.
Usually once per week.
They also have financial aid available
that you can apply for.
If you need help,
you can afford it.
Great,
wonderful.
Beautiful.
What a great service with better help.
You're not wasting time traveling,
going to and fro.
A lot of people have trouble face to
face with people.
It's embarrassing.
It's tough.
It's hard,
but this is a beautiful thing about
this.
The service you're online,
you can have video,
you can have a chat.
Whatever you're comfortable with,
whatever level with they're there to
help you out.
A lot of people are not comfortable
talking to therapist so that best way to
do it,
to get in the door is with better help.
When I was at my worst with anxiety,
it was so.
It was impossible for me to go into an
office and get the help that I needed.
That's the beautiful thing about better
help.
So guys,
if you want me to talk to somebody for
any reason at all,
this is the way to try it out.
Go to better help.com/h
three.
Give it a shot.
You deserve it.
Help yourself out with better help.
Thank you for sponsoring us.
Welcome back to the.
Basically,
if you're looking for opinions,
look no further.
This podcast and this is the opinion
podcast experience,
whatever that means.
I honestly,
I'm a little flustered because I'm just
not used to this three minute breaks.
Just ran back from the bathroom and
literally Dan was like,
hurry up,
like jumped into the seat.
Literally four seconds.
He's got my paper towel.
So as promised guys,
we've got a thrill ride here,
lined up.
This video shocked me.
Okay.
So I've been educated.
That's good.
It wasn't before this video shocked me
frankly,
like no video I've seen in a long time.
And the story,
the scoop originally was that it was
fully monetized for a long time,
which I get,
I guess you can only blame you for so
much.
It's called do vegans actually taste
better?
So it's like how,
how does youtube know that a dude is
guzzling his own Jizz on camera?
The part that really gets me about this
video by the way,
Gay God damn measurement called
Jugaad whose name I kind of liked that
the Jugaad.
So the thing that really gets me is that
he's a key Jesus and like a little kind
of medicine cup and then he tastes it
and then he's like,
he loves it,
but then he drinks it three more times
and he finishes the Cup and I am
actually getting nauseous as I did that
too.
So this video is clearly per.
So you definitely,
if you're going to drink,
you have kids on camera like that.
You're definitely the gay God.
Not many people can step to you on that
level.
Autumn of this.
Do you begin to actually taste better?
And I have actually been Vegan for 12
years,
over 12 years.
So who better to test this theory that
me,
myself,
and I haven't really tasted myself in
quite a while.
What the fuck is wrong?
Is this nothing weird?
Like you're supposed to know what he's
talking about.
He's drank his own tj's nobody didn't
say that yet.
It's just saying I haven't tasted myself
in a while.
Like you're supposed to know what that
means.
People watching readily gay God know
what that means.
I'm subscribed to [inaudible] channel
serious on his channel.
But like how frequently are you drinking
your own con?
Huh?
But how is this not like a weird fetish
like drinking or common front of people
publicly is kind of.
Probably is.
Yeah.
So I might have went ahead and shot a
little bit of myself into this shot
glass and I kind of want to be open and
honest with you guys and tell you what
they actually tastes like.
Suggested my first time experiencing 10
inches.
That's what it says in the top right?
This is certainly the gay God might do,
but like what?
I just don't understand.
Like you're,
you can be gay.
Like obviously no one cares that you're
gay in this day and age,
but like when your whole identity,
everything you do and talk about and is
like a bow like that you're gay.
It's like there's gotta be more to you
than that.
Everything's about like,
I drink matches.
I took a 10 inch cock.
It's like there's gotta be more to you
than that
tube game that everyone's trying to play
now.
And like everything's got to be so crazy
like we used to.
Oh,
we did this video of tasting different
sodas and weird flavors.
I forgot to tell you that one.
This is,
this is.
No,
it's like gotten this far.
It tasting gross sodas is not enough
anymore.
Know what he should've done is be like,
this is a black guys or white guys is a
vegans jazz.
Well,
it's not done.
You know,
I watched it all.
No,
and when the videos
five times because face right now.
All right,
well anyway,
well I'll have to bookmark of the.
My first time I took 10 inches for a
related to Austin the other day.
No,
Tmi and I'll buy you.
Don't you only live once the bottom up?
No,
just kidding.
Okay.
He's not just kidding though.
He drinks it all like throughout the
video when I saw that,
I was like,
oh thank God it's not.
It's actually just clickbait,
but I promise he drinks at all and I
don't know if I even need to
necessarily.
Yeah,
I'll know.
I'll keep watching it.
I'll know when I've had enough.
You tell me when you're done watching
this.
Okay.
Because I don't,
you know,
I'll shut up
obviously like I let the gait belt with
a whole bunch of different guy.
Not a whole bunch what was making myself
sound a little sweaty,
but I feel that yeah,
holding a cup of your own ges and you're
about to drink it.
You don't need help.
Sonic slutty
meat eaters.
They're so salty,
which is weird because I um,
I eat a lot of salt but all my exes are
like,
yeah,
you're really sweet tasting.
And I'm like,
how has that been?
Like I eat like 10 times as much salt as
you,
but I guess it has to do with like red
meat consumption and all that stuff.
So they are always in that sense
you've had enough.
You will want to see him drink or should
we really?
It did it.
He did it here.
Let's see.
Let's hit a drink here.
Potent smelling like it kind of.
Oh,
he drank from already.
It looks like less and volume.
Oh,
there you go.
So I'm basically like,
well let's see what I smell like taking
the sniff of his own kid.
Okay,
I'm getting late.
So let's hit the button on this.
You don't want to see him hit it?
No,
not really.
You don't want to see him throw it back
a bit.
That people will see it.
Throw it back.
Yeah.
Like warm,
Sunny d,
like if an artist.
All right,
I'm going to bounce out of this one.
Yeah.
You guys want to continue this sog on
your own.
Head on over to gay.
God.
He's the god of the gays.
Gay Gay God.
I want to be Jugaad Jugaad,
the great thinker of the dark web.
What was that group of people?
You're saying Yo,
the intellectual darkweb yes.
I'm the.
I'm the Jew.
God of the intellectual dark web.
What is this?
Intellectual dark web.
It's like a collection of all these
Jordan Peterson.
I'm finally and others and others.
So am I going to be inducted into that
for my research into and we'll see more
results you're bringing back.
When do your research.
How do we have any interesting calls yet
at the end?
Uh,
he's in the middle of screening right
now.
Dan.
I don't think I'm logged into the call.
Oh my God.
I'll tell you right now.
Yeah.
You still looking for one?
Okay.
Next up
break.
Invasion is back.
He's dodging a lie.
I'm trying to get ahold of him and he's
been dodging me a little bit.
That's okay.
Once I tell them I'm the Jew,
God,
he'll do a little bit more
today.
It's kissing plank.
I'm starting to like Chris mentioned a
video gets a thousand thumbs up.
Six days.
Manager said six.
Nine.
Oh,
come on.
All the audio is like,
so people know what the hell are gone.
I panicked.
I thought it was high and but now that
that's his style,
his style is like torn and destroy the
audio as much as possible.
They always take a decision.
I'm telling you,
watch his past 20 beers are all like
peaked out of this planet
six,
nine edition.
If this video gets 100,000
thumbs up six days,
why is there a group of uh,
what's going on behind you?
What is it trying to look like here?
What is this?
So there's this rapper six nine.
Yeah,
I'll show you
six,
nine.
This guy
you've seen him.
He's a,
he's,
he's like a meme,
right?
Yeah.
Bed Six.
Nine will come on the guaranteed to get
the most kids.
Try it.
Let's do it.
Alright.
So here's the game guys.
I have gotten
no word that if you can somehow smash
100,000
likes on this video,
if we can get 100,000
live viewers right now,
prank invasion will come on the show as
a guest and kiss me.
What if I kissed Chris?
Would that be shocking?
Would that be good tv?
Yeah.
If we do a quick video as if he comes in
here,
we kind of do need to play a quick game
for a quick kiss.
Me and him.
Yeah.
No,
not me.
Not,
you know,
I went through.
I wouldn't volunteer for that,
but with you,
you're kind of damaged honestly.
Once you kissed Chris,
I wonder if we could also get a girl in
here like act or.
No?
No.
Okay.
I'll do it.
I'll fucking do it.
I swear to God.
I'll do it.
I'll do a quick answer.
A quick kiss.
I swear to God and noises.
I'll do it dude.
You think I'm not?
I'll deal with this fully narrowed
asshole to me.
It would grab your ass.
Full Lynyrd.
[inaudible].
Sexy turn.
See how he pulls this girl at six.
Nine style
can sound like six.
Nine.
You got to give me a really,
really quick.
Hits your down.
Okay.
Here I go.
She's like,
Yup.
Nailed it.
She,
she,
I irresistible even trying.
And you know where it goes from here.
I got to say I love Chris.
It's getting to the point where it's
just so good.
Is making parodies of himself at this
point.
Yeah.
No,
it's turned.
It's really turning into something
special.
We've got current events.
We've got everything to talk about
everything going on in the world.
I'm going to tell you guys about it now.
Enter the current events experience,
drug overdoses up 10 percent and the US.
What is going on?
Well,
it's mostly from prescription drugs.
Actually shouldn't really surprise
anyone,
but I haven't been following the story.
And then here you can see by year at
chart basically since 2016 and to this
date it's shot up.
These are all synthetic opioids.
Basically pain prescribed prescription
painkillers way worse than heroin.
Yeah,
like almost double that that if you go.
It's interesting if you go back to like
2012,
2013,
it was the least deadly.
Although what's going on in the US,
if you go back to 1999,
people weren't really dying from drugs
but somehow unliked and turn the end of
this century.
Everybody's what's going on.
People are profiting from it and heroin,
cocaine,
but it's like all going up.
Is this a cultural issue or is this.
Well,
you could,
you could say the,
the whole graph going up.
Maybe it's a cultural issue,
but yeah,
that one spike on the synthetic opioids,
right?
Is Not.
I am.
I am very curious about the cultural
issue of why in the past 2015 or 15 to
20 years or is everybody dying from
like,
what the fuck?
I wonder if there's some explanation or
visit.
Just life has become so unbearable.
You know,
it's like,
let's take away health care,
let's put everyone in that and let's
just give them some opiates to fucking
kill themselves on.
It's become a lot hard.
I'll tell you what.
Life's become a lot harder.
If you go back to 1999,
people could buy houses that could
afford rent and over these past two
decades it's gotten a lot harder to live
a lot more expensive,
blow harder to get medical treatment.
I don't know if that's a relation by.
That's pretty sad.
There's a bigger conversation here
besides affect everyone's dying on
opioids,
but that is the story here now.
I've been watching.
I just find it so ironic,
like let me open this again.
That there's this war on drugs like
marijuana.
First of all,
I'm not a marijuana user and I think
that it's benefits and is greatly
exaggerated.
I don't think marijuana is an innocent
truck,
but I do find it absolutely the
greatest,
probably the single greatest problem
with our society is the fact that one
percent of Americans are in prison,
most of them for harmless drug offense.
So it's like we're locking up marijuana
users
and meanwhile
doctors and pharmaceutical companies are
openly poisoning people and I mean we're
talking about 30,000
deaths.
That's a small subset of people who were
addicted,
whose lives are being ruined because
they're taking so many of these opiates
and doctors are just giving them out
like fucking candy because they're
getting kickbacks.
There's like three big companies who are
distributed all this and they know
exactly what they were doing and oh
yeah,
that's just what it is.
We saw the 60 minutes,
um,
report about this,
how there was like little pain clinics
opening up.
That's when we seen them.
I've seen them all over the place.
I'm like,
what is that pain clinic?
And apparently you can just walk in and
a doctor will prescribe you a painkiller
and it's also predictive.
Don't give you anything.
They'll give you oxycontin.
They'll be any opiate,
any crazy shit you want.
Just be like,
hey my,
hey doc,
my back hurts and these crooked ass
doctor,
they're just writing prescriptions all
day long.
My Dad,
he um,
he had like some arthritic pain in his
wrist and this doctor gave him like an
unlimited supply of like really intense
painkillers.
And I was like,
Whoa,
like if he actually took kids so easy.
And I mean this is an ongoing issue.
It's not like a,
it's not like doesn't abilitative his
life,
right?
He doesn't.
Nothing in my opinion that a little
tylenol or Ibuprofen couldn't resolve.
But like,
that's insane.
That's so crazy what's going on there.
And anyway,
in the 60 minutes report that I hired,
they would come in.
They were showing how these huge
pharmaceutical companies are basically
con always lobbying congress to not
enforce or regulate or control at all
this,
this growing issue.
They showed like for example,
like there was one town like this is
really ravaging like poor white
communities.
It seems like in rural America,
like Arkansas and Alabama and
Mississippi,
there was like a small town in
Mississippi or somewhere that had
imported so many and sold so many
painkillers that it was something like
50 pills for every resident of the city.
Hm.
Which means that they were probably just
selling it to drug dealers,
but like there's glaring problems here.
Have everyone dropped it like this,
this is,
this is so sick and,
and the government's not doing anything
about it because there's so much a
lobbying money and meanwhile we're
lucking up marijuana users.
Yeah.
So that's pretty nuts.
That really grinds my gears.
You know,
I just hate this whole,
like moral.
There's always this moral argument from
like army.
I mean,
Jeff sessions,
the attorney general thinks that
marijuana should be like a federal
crime.
Like he's staunchly against legalizing
marijuana.
It's like,
okay dude,
what are you doing about this shit?
Like glad that you got your moral
imperative about marijuana and,
and relatively harmless drugs.
What are you doing about this shit so
twisted man.
Fucking can you believe that?
It's like Tiawana up there.
I've driven past few places when I'm
driving around town.
You see like a pain clinic.
I was like,
what does that mean,
a pain clinic?
What do you,
what do you do there?
I never imagined that it was actually
just people giving prescription drugs
out like nothing.
I have no idea.
So I'm just writing what you were
talking about and uh,
yeah.
And like all of a sudden there is a
small town and the pharmacy will be
buying 50 times the amount that a normal
pharmacy right is buying.
Yeah.
And it's like they're just turning a
blind eye,
just letting it happen
because the pharmaceutical drug
companies that are lobbying the shit out
of him and blocking it.
It's like congress is so twisted.
These guys are so fucking corrupt.
It's like scary.
Not to mention the,
that the water is turning frogs gay.
That's a whole nother issue.
Um,
do you want to talk about this airplane
story Ilah or did we find it too little,
too sad
when you already brought it up?
Yeah.
Well,
come on.
Is this the video you put together?
Where's the one you put together,
Dan?
The,
uh,
the edit,
it's a shared with you,
shared with me where here,
I'll drop it in the inner chat right
now.
Um,
this story isn't weird and wild man and
it's kind
of sad.
It's very sad.
I'm this guy,
I'm not sure how he even got in the car,
works in airplane.
Like how is it so easy to just,
there's no key.
You think he masterminded this.
It's not easy,
right?
Figuring out if this guy works at an
airplane in Seattle and he just stole
the airplane and went for a joy ride,
but his intention was,
was to commit suicide.
And what's so intriguing about it is
basically this conversation was recorded
between him and air control of air
control.
Being like,
hey man,
you know,
bring it,
bring it down.
And he's just,
he's just so casual about it.
It just seems like he's having a good
time.
Uh,
Dan,
I don't see it.
Just drop the Lincoln,
the,
it didn't work.
I clicked it.
I think I need it.
But here I've got it in your email.
So here,
let's pop this up,
right?
Twenty one year old.
Hold on with me for a second.
So interesting
plane around.
You seem comfortable with that.
What's so crazy?
Is this what you guys are seeing as all
footage people shop from the ground
because this guy was like,
I'm going to try doing barrel rolls and
all these tricks because his intention
was to die.
So he was almost just like.
But he was,
he was performing some pretty amazing so
being like don't want to hurt people on
the street.
So he was also careful of that.
Yeah.
Really interesting.
No,
he definitely wasn't going to hurt
anyone
and you can see all the terrain around
and you've got no issue with visibility
or anything.
I got some gas to go check out the
Olympics and rich are able to tell
without the tutor at.
They're just not taking it's any jets.
I'm actually keeping you away from
aircraft trying to land at Seatac,
you know,
screwing up everyone else's day.
Oh,
hopefully went charter because it's
going down jail time.
I mean I would hope it is for a guy like
me.
We're not going to worry or think about
that,
but could you start?
I believe so.
I'm still working on an issue average.
Don't say stuff like that.
He better than trying to lay in it like
I know how to put the landing
for the record.
Know.
I think it would give you pull this off.
You want it to land court field.
You wanted to try.
That might be the best way to set up and
see if we can land there because I don't
think I'd be happy with you.
The you that I did this year that I did
this.
I would like to apologize to each and
every one of them.
I guess I never really knew it.
Alrighty.
Hey,
find the guy to a,
a,
a back flip ramp.
It's amazing.
But guys,
seriously shit.
You're fucking feeling bad man.
Definitely don't steal a plane,
but little followup to that somewhat
depressing story.
This is charming,
charming stuff here.
No,
I'm just saying these guys are posing at
the same exact.
Are you serious?
Come on.
You gotta.
Love that.
They both.
Come on.
Give me a fucking break.
Would you?
Would you please give me a fucking
break?
We've got a double proposal here at
Disneyland for.
They're crying the freaking out.
That's at the magic castle.
Come on guys.
Give me a fucking break here.
We've got a double proposal.
Am I right?
This warms my heart.
I'm going to lie.
I said,
you know what?
He pulled the ring out.
You had to ring.
She was very cute about it too.
She was like,
I don't know what to do with.
Both of them were very much like,
hmm.
Love it.
So there you go guys.
We get it balanced.
We bring balance here on the HD podcast.
This is too much of a roller coaster
peaks and valleys.
This I've told you,
this is the premier experience on the
Internet today.
Maximum highs,
maximum.
Lowe's better help.
This one.
Okay.
We went from sadness to joy and now to
rage.
This next story is really is really made
me rage full.
We were covering the whole spectrum of
emotions here.
We have some college before we take this
and let's get some serious.
Yeah.
Uh,
we got a few.
You want me to do a put one three,
right?
Yeah.
What's their name?
All right.
Let's see.
How do I do it?
Because I want to make sure that I can.
Uh,
I can shoot you the link if you want to
right now.
Send me on discord if you would please.
Okay.
Let me do one more story while you get
that set up in the backroom.
That sounds good.
You're like,
why don't you,
uh,
once you set me up an 87 year old woman
gets tased while cutting flowers,
Dan.
All right,
thank you.
That's what we've got coming.
Shit doesn't work.
You know what?
Let's just says logged out.
And this is a whole mess.
I mean,
how long is it gonna take.
What do we got it.
We got two seconds here on the clock
guys.
Hope you're all doing good and having a
great time here at the podcast
experience.
We're logging into our call studio so we
can get the feedback of the geniuses,
frankly,
that listen to the show,
the great minds,
the great minds out there that.
Listen to this show.
Dan,
how do you wipe since we've got your
hair?
Uh,
I,
I do it the opposite of you.
Uh,
actually the norm,
what I would say is traditional.
Yeah,
you're,
you're a righty.
I'm a lefty.
Let's be frank.
It's not that now,
do you go dry or wet?
I guess I go try.
I mean,
I feel kind of ashamed and,
and kind of ashamed of.
We shamed normal.
Which try a white ball now.
Dan,
do you ever feel that you just can't
clean it?
Oh yeah.
And do you give up or do you wipe to the
point where it's like,
because usually with dry wiping your
ass,
you come to a crossroad where you're
like,
I give up too early or do I injure my
anus?
So where do you,
where do you fall in that crossroad?
Yeah.
Um,
no,
I,
I've,
I've been there and it definitely,
it's a risky road.
I mean,
I can,
I'm like you.
I mean I'm,
I'm,
I've got hair.
So,
you know,
it gets rough.
It gets real rough.
Sometimes you take the uh,
under wiping or the overwhelming,
I got to say I probably do the
overwhelming because that's the other
way.
It's not okay.
That's not tolerable.
So it's not really an option.
Not for me either.
No.
Have you bled from wiping?
It may be.
Maybe I probably don't check enough.
I'm a little like,
I don't know.
I don't turn around and check out my
business after.
I'm not ashamed to admit that I've,
I've bled from wiping.
I have,
I have to say what's going on here?
I've got to grab their password.
We this.
Uh,
we've,
we've distracted.
Then you've bled from wiping Ian.
Have you bled from wiping?
He said you now,
Dan,
you say May.
Probably.
Did everyone maybes an insufficient
answer?
I don't.
I don't turn around and check.
Do you not look?
Every time you wipe,
do you look at what point do you look?
Occasionally you don't look.
You don't look at the last wipe.
How do you know your claim?
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Well,
yeah,
I guess.
I guess in that sense I do look yes.
But I'm not like taking.
Thank you.
I fully take it out.
I inspect it thoroughly.
You have like a magnifying glass and
they frankly,
I even looked,
I,
I generally even look at the first wipe,
right?
Yeah.
He lives with me.
Thank you.
Now,
Dan,
would you say that we all got our fresh
uniform and has your finger ever slipped
through the toilet paper?
Because the what?
I mean the driver didn't know Dan,
so yeah.
And then if so it's followed by like 30
minutes of scrubbing my hands
afterwards.
Good.
Alright,
we're in.
Thank you Dan.
Thank you for the anecdotes and fixing
my computer and thank you to a thank you
specifically to charms for the flushable
wipes.
Oh,
I got to hear this.
I'm kyle.
I don't know if you're on the air.
Tell me about the.
Tell me about your life or not.
I don't want to know everything but
specifically about the lyme disease.
Oh Man.
You Open?
Yeah.
Let's,
let's cut to the chase here.
Yeah,
so I'm a geocasher or if you don't know
what Geo caching is,
say a little like cps based treasure
hunt,
a scavenger hunt type game and a lot of
caching takes place out in the woods on
trails and whatnot.
So before I started this,
I was never a,
never a hiker,
never spent much time outdoors.
Um,
so I quickly learned that,
you know,
you're on a trail for awhile sometime
nature calls and uh,
let me literally,
and uh,
you know,
if you're like a couple miles from your
car or something,
a couple miles from a restroom,
you just got to find a spot to take care
of business.
Um,
so,
so you had the first time that's
happened.
I'm a,
I'm a hairy guy,
much like you.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's not,
it's never good.
Never comes out clean.
So the first time this happened I,
uh,
you know,
you always hear this and I,
I always thought it was Kinda like a
joke,
but I don't know if you always hear
this,
but yeah,
I use the least to kind of clean up the
business factor.
And a is not preferable,
but I quickly learned because I mean,
as far as my normal wiping routine goes,
I'm a dry wet guy,
so I'll go my first one,
first one will be a toilet paper and
then I got the baby was right by the
toilet that second.
And then I just kind of go back and
forth.
You kind of,
it's a good way to kind of feel out the
situation without having to inspect it
after every white because I,
you know,
so let's.
So let's go to the,
the pivotal moment of the story.
Yeah.
So,
um,
this wasn't so on another occasion
because I started packing toilet paper
in my,
like hiking backpack.
But on this one particular occasion I
had run out where I forgot it.
So I do not have it with me.
So,
uh,
you know,
I live up in Rhode Island,
we ticks,
ticks are very prevalent thing up here.
And when did these as well.
So,
um,
so I've never had an issue with ticks on
my life,
but on this particular occasion when I
popped the squat,
did my business,
didn't have the toilet paper.
So I just did the leaf technique to uh,
do uh,
you know,
kind of take care of things a bit.
Wow.
Did you get a tick on your penis?
Not In my anus,
but uh,
like two days later I felt something.
I think actually I felt something in my
groin area to say that I don't want to
talk about what I was doing.
What were you doing when you noticed the
tick when you were jerking off?
You said that
Kyle,
were you able to send it?
Did you finish when you,
when you found the tech error or did you
decide to deal with it at the time or
later?
That,
that ruined the moment.
Yeah.
I couldn't see what was going on.
I was in bed.
Where on your groin was the tick
located?
It was like right
in there.
Like I'm a big dude so,
you know,
like I got some,
I got thick thighs.
Sure.
So,
so it wasn't,
that's why I probably missed it because
I always do like a check after it was
like,
um,
like between the time it was deep,
it was like,
it was,
it,
it was in there and it felt like when
you say deeper,
was it under the balls?
Was it between the balls and the thigh?
Was it next to the peanut?
It was like,
yeah,
in the ball between the ball thigh area
right over there.
That's how,
that's how I felt.
I felt.
I felt that area.
You might have been cutting your balls
or something when you were jerking off.
Right.
To feel that there is something special
for yourself,
you gotta treat yourself.
I totally,
definitely.
Most definitely.
So what happens when you have a take
there?
What do you do?
Good question.
Well,
yeah,
so I mean,
you know,
someone,
you spend time hiking and whatnot,
especially around here,
you know,
you always hear about it.
So I mean,
I was freaking out,
first of all because I never had a tick
bite before,
so I already knew the,
the way you want to get rid of it when
you want it,
when.
Yeah.
So when you take it out,
you don't want to like break the ticks
body or leave that was in like
underneath,
like it's burrowed in the skin,
like some of it.
So did you,
uh,
the techniques?
I use tweezers,
pull it out and it,
you grab it and then you rotate it.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
And it was tricky and hard to see.
I mean I started.
Do you have,
do you trim your pubic hair or are you
fully a bushed?
It depends when
at the time,
you know,
and
when it's um,
it was probably some Bush happening at
that time.
Right?
So the visibility was low.
Oh yeah.
There's a lot of bushwhacking going on.
And so this,
this son of a bitch gave you lyme
disease.
Yeah,
I started,
wound really shitty,
horrible.
And now it's like why am,
is a terrible thing?
I mean,
I don't have it as bad as some people,
but it's kind of just with me now,
like every year this happened about
three years,
two years ago maybe.
And um,
yeah,
so like once every,
you know,
once or twice a year now,
like I was,
had like really bad migraine,
like body aches just kind of shuts me
down for like a day.
It's just like with me,
even though I went on antibiotics and
whatnot,
it's just something that sometimes it
gets rid of it completely.
Sometimes it just lingers.
So what is the kind of moral of the
story?
I'm wondering,
don't,
don't go out in nature.
The moral,
the moral of the story is,
I'm not sure what,
what does that mean?
What is the,
what are we getting out of this?
Kyle?
I'm not sure.
I was going down a different path that I
was fucking Ian and then somehow we got
on this story.
I liked it.
I got to tell you.
Well I'm sorry you got lyme disease.
That's awful.
But on the plus side,
I mean the masturbating probably was,
was definitely worked in your favor.
And this time would have stayed longer,
I would have been even worse off.
So really.
So is that the longer that ticks in you
the worst?
The lyme disease?
Yeah,
because I hadn't quite another time
like,
and um,
I noticed,
I know for a fact I noticed it within
like,
you know,
an hour.
So it has for the most part people say
it has to be in there for like 24 to 72
hours for that to be a transmitted.
I'm very glad it was in there for like
two days.
So very glad you decided to masturbate
that on that when you did.
And I thank you for sharing that story
with me.
But I'm also curious,
what is it you said,
what the hell are you doing out in the
forest?
You're looking for treasure.
It's a game,
I guess hobby with my call.
It's called Geo caching.
So basically what it is is someone like
me or whoever else,
Geo caches hide the container somewhere
out in the woods or out.
So there's so many.
I mean there are over 3 million of these
geo caches around the world.
Basically people go look for them,
they use gps coordinates to find where
they are.
Once you're in the location
and then you have to try to find it.
Is it,
is there something valuable?
Do you find what's going on in this box?
Is it other than just text with lyme
disease?
You know,
there won't be.
It won't be.
The rule is if you take something out of
it,
you're supposed to put something back
in.
Do you still.
Sorry,
what was that?
Do you still geocache for you?
God bless.
Yeah,
it definitely has ruined being outdoors.
I'm way more paranoid now.
Whenever I am out in the woods.
I used to like pick check only whenever
I got back to the car after I was done.
Now it's like every
20 to 30 minutes on the trail and like.
Let me check.
Yeah.
Well thank you carl for sharing your
story.
I hope this is a cautionary tale that
everyone out there don't go outside.
I mean that's the moral that I pulled
from this.
I don't expose you asshole to the.
To the,
to the conditional.
Right,
exactly.
Keep your asshole clean and cover my
dues.
Kyle.
Thank you for sharing that wonderful
story with us and I wish you all the
best and I hope that lyme disease.
Keep it.
Yeah,
keep cash in my dog.
Okay,
appreciate it.
Thanks guys.
Always.
We always end with a wet.
One minute.
Thank you.
Wow.
That was an interesting man.
We've got travis here who uses female
razors for asshole shaving only.
That's not that surprising.
The same says he's a sandpaper in.
What the hell is this?
He's shaking his head.
No,
he said.
He said,
where's the box guy?
Is that guy still on?
No,
I just see travis talking razors and
John who saw the handover.
Oh,
bummer.
While we can.
That was a great one.
Happy with Kyle Up.
This story mean it didn't.
It didn't really add to our knowledge
base,
but it was a great know if we can join
the great minds.
He's not a great way to collect.
I mean he's a poor minds collective.
He got on a Dick,
but he's a great guy and he's a funny
guy.
You know?
Interesting guy.
Kept living you guys.
Never did the Geo caching thing that was
like,
yeah,
I went on a few of those.
We don't live in the house.
If you haven't got what it was big like
a while ago.
Have you done.
Have you ever done this thing of walking
outside?
Forget about Geo caching.
That's way too high level.
Wow.
Thank you,
Kyle.
That was a great story.
Damn,
you don't.
I've got.
I've had a tick before.
Obviously.
Maybe I have lyme disease.
Maybe that's why I'm so lazy when.
That'd be great to have an excuse now.
It's dramatic,
man.
It's awful.
Oh God.
It's a fucking little creature burrowed,
but lyme disease is more prevalent on
the east coast.
No,
you're.
You're good.
Why do.
Anyway,
Kyle love you.
Let's move on.
I'm 87 year old woman.
Taste.
Take the old bitch out is what I say.
She had a common.
I love these stories about place.
Now let me.
Let me.
Let me say this guy.
I respect police officers or respect the
job.
I respect what they do,
but I have a lot of buts.
First of all,
you signed up for a dangerous job and
you're well compensated.
You can go work in a fucking cafe if you
don't want to be in harm's way.
Okay.
Nobody asked you or forced you to sign
up to be a cop.
The same goes for the military and I'm
sorry,
but my opinions,
the right opinions,
and if you disagree with me,
you're just clearly wrong.
Why do I first of all
back when the story so people can join
your 87 year old woman while cutting
dandelion?
There's no justification.
I'm going to tell the story though,
but I'm on A.
I'm A.
I want to.
I want to talk about the rant about the
military.
Oh yeah.
Let me just finish this one point.
As you tried to save me.
Being in the military doesn't make you a
hero by default,
but thank you for your service.
Thank you for your service.
You signed up.
Did it?
Look,
it's
a risky job.
It's there.
It's the first part.
You Go.
You travel around with a gun and hostile
territory.
Same with the.
You walk around with a gun on your hip
for a region,
it's dangerous and you signed up for it.
It doesn't make you automatically a hero
and it doesn't mean that you have the
right to never be in harm's way because
the police training in the United States
is basically if you are any risk shoot
to kill deadly force when you're
confronted with the 87 year old woman
with a steak knife in her hand that was
used to cut dandelions,
which is adorable,
as fucking gets to make a salad for a
husband.
God.
So she's out there cutting dandelions
and the police,
first of all that she wanders across the
street,
she's probably a little,
uh,
she doesn't speak English and she was on
some guy's property.
She probably didn't know it was,
uh,
it was the ymcas or some shit or the
boys and girls club,
but they call.
She was probably a little dementia or a
little senile.
Right.
So the guys,
cause I have a recording,
but he says she's over here with a knife
and she seems lost.
That's why he called.
They're like,
is she trying to stab people?
He said,
no,
she's not dangerous.
She's not trying to harm anyone.
She seems lost.
That's why he calls.
So the police show up with arms with
their guns drawn,
screaming,
you know,
dropped.
Can you imagine that?
A sweet old lady with the little like
steak knife cutting dandelions shredder
was like,
what's going on?
So I'm going to tase you.
Shredder looking intimidating like you
cannot.
You have to draw the line somewhere.
You're signed up for dangerous job.
Okay.
You have to draw the line somewhere.
If some 87,
that the choice between tasing and 87
year old woman and possibly receiving a
knife strike from an 87 year old women,
you have to weigh the severity of these
two situations.
Can you imagine this old,
87 year old too crippled lady,
she's all fastigiate.
All of a sudden she's like,
Oh,
I'm at 86.
She's all strong and fast out to kill.
No,
the training is fucked.
It's fucked.
You are not entitled to a perfect
harmless existence because you're a cop.
You signed up for that job and I
appreciate that.
You're serving the community and you're
doing this wonderful dangerous job that
somebody has to do,
but you could have gone,
you know,
you could have,
could have done anything.
I just feel like any normal person in
that situation would like.
The thing was that she was walking
towards them when they said,
drop the knife,
drop the fucking dog.
It's like if you were in
that situation,
what will you do?
You just,
you'll let her walk to you and you'll
deal with it.
Don't draw guns.
You put your down and say hi,
can I help you?
You okay?
It's like an old lady.
How about you just go and grab her hand
and takes a knife out of her hand
because she's an 87 year old woman.
How about you just do this?
Are you okay?
Take one.
We'll shoot you bitch.
There's a problem here guys.
There's a problem with our police
killing people.
She didn't die,
but
okay.
She doesn't rush to the store.
Spoiler alert either.
You ruin the story.
Yeah.
That was a major question.
Should this.
After an officer in Georgia taste at 87
year old woman who was cutting the
alliance with a knife,
Steve Lipson saw me.
His take.
What's up for them?
It your ass.
Imagine that.
Just look at her and so sad.
She probably hit the floor like a bag of
dirt.
dandelions.
She probably got injured.
She got to fall in this age.
Yeah.
You don't heal very fast if you make a
price.
She's alive.
I mean frankly speaking,
I mean God,
look at that threat,
that menace to society.
Damn.
She had a common woman is actually
facing charges this morning.
Oh,
that's the best part.
I didn't even tell you the best part.
Well,
I'll let them speak for it.
She's getting charged.
It is.
This is a misunderstanding on so many
different levels facing charges,
but she has a court appearance next
month,
this 87 year old grandmother who doesn't
speak English and is charged this
morning with criminal trespass and
obstruction of an officer.
There's no kids around telling me she
doesn't speak English.
A worker at a boys and girls club in
Chatsworth,
Georgia called police Monday after
seeing her walking with a knife in a
field on their property,
it turns out she lives across the street
and this from Syria was a steak knife
and she handled it with your family.
Exterior was a steak.
It's attendance.
Just a regular knife.
Like a kitchen?
Yeah,
no knife.
And she was there picking Dandelions,
which your family explains was meant for
a salad for her husband.
Police say she even had a bag full of
weeds.
Even the worker who called nine,
one one that we'd deal,
bitches got.
We'd take her out,
sprinkle a little crack on her.
She was mysteriously found with crack on
her.
Okay.
This 87 year old crack attic pulled a
weapon with a bag of weed on set.
Wasn't threatening.
She came out with someone with a nice
ride or did he just have it?
Police arrived with guns drawn,
telling her to put down the knife,
but say she wouldn't.
They say they even threw a knife to the
ground trying to explain.
Put down the night.
She won't put the knife down.
They explained she wouldn't put the
knife down,
got him
thing.
What they wanted her to do.
When she kept walking towards them,
they shot her with a stun gun.
The police chief was there during the
incident,
deployed the Taser rather than using
deadly force.
He says his officer acted appropriately.
Her family says that her age,
the shock could have killed her.
She's recovering.
Um,
you know,
it's still little.
So Kyla,
anyone.
Nobody should be tasered but especially.
Well,
I mean if it's like a 30 year old man,
a young 18 year old man,
woman,
sure protect yourself.
But I love that the police chief comes
out and is like,
oh yeah,
no,
they reacted perfectly.
We endorse fully tasing grandma's
children.
Really?
If you're stepping towards us,
we're going to take.
If you're walking away from us,
we'll still you.
Yeah,
we'll take you in the back.
MMM.
A little sore from what?
She's gone through facing charges.
And there's one thing we should add
about that young man who was speaking
out for the family.
Robin,
he is the nephew of this woman and he's
a former police officer and he says,
well,
he understands why the officers use
their taser.
He wishes they had used a little more
common sense.
Yeah.
Thanks for bringing that up,
Steve.
Very much.
Yes.
The nephew said procedurally the
officers did the right thing,
but it's kind of like being aware of the
circumstance
procedurally.
It's all good,
but it's like it's an 87 year old woman.
Love it.
Yes,
and maybe it was a little tough.
Sometimes everything is not exactly by
the book.
Well,
the best part she was being.
She has to appear in court for like,
I'm cruising around with a knife now
they're going to charge her to make it
look all kosher.
Like let's just,
let's not waste the justice system's
time either.
She's being charged with criminal
trespassing and obstruction of an
officer.
You've tasted her bro.
So
I was at.
Was that Rachel?
You could say that pose revealed the UK
that people want Edra Elba to replace
Daniel Craig as double o seven James
Bond.
But here's the catch.
Isla,
he's black.
Oh,
he's a black man.
Apparently that's caused a lot of drama.
People say James Bond has to be white.
Here's my take.
You Want my opinion?
Isla [inaudible].
You want to know?
You guys want to know how to feel about
this.
I love it.
I love,
I love address Elba.
I mean people voted for it.
Well,
what else do you need?
That's the best part.
This was a public vote and the UK with a
list of five names and people voted for
Idris and I love that.
Now everyone's like,
oh,
you can't be bond because you're black.
When I heard that,
I was like,
Oh,
well,
I love that.
Not,
not even.
This is why I love this story so much.
It's almost like heartwarming
how much people haven't thought about
race in this because when I heard that I
was like this,
I just love him as an actor.
He Suave,
he's cool.
He's a bad ass ever since I saw him in
the wire.
Then in love with him as an actor.
I think he's great and I think he'd be
an awesome double,
like double o seven.
I thought it was great.
Um,
but apparently a lot of people are
unhappy with the,
with the scoop.
In fact there's a video that some grown
man.
Was it you said Dan about it,
about her or in general it's like,
well,
here this Guy James Bomb.
Let's watch this video first I guess,
but let's see it.
Somebody made a really great point here.
They're like James Bond,
English,
American,
Scottish,
Australian,
Welsh,
Irish.
It's like,
oh,
the other actors that played him.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like he's an idea.
He's cool.
He swapped,
he's a spy.
He's a bad ass of all the things I think
about when I think of double seven white
is not like number one.
Oh,
he's a white guy.
Double seven white.
Cool.
Suave,
like down at number 15 or something.
I don't.
It's not on the list.
Right?
You're like,
I think he had top.
If you ask someone as right,
top 10 attributes of James Swan,
if you write what you're kind of weird
white,
make some great points.
Also,
I love her intro.
As Dan pointed out.
To me the world is incorrect.
Ah,
look at this.
Everything is going
right.
The stage is set.
Hopkins world.
No
interests.
Elva you shot is really powerful.
Why is it okay?
Here we go.
Thanks.
Bond.
You will not be below seven.
You say it like you will not be like.
Is that how do you.
Why are you so sure about that?
Over dead body?
That's a how many tweets you put out
saying,
I'm Elba.
Idris Elba.
It's not because you're a gentleman of
color.
It's because a gentleman of color.
Hm?
You don't like black people deal lady or
a gentlemen of Color.
James Bond isn't.
He's written as an upper class.
Our good white top form with a silver
spoon in his mouth.
Why can't that person be black?
Do you hear what you're saying?
He's written as an upper class snobbish
silver spoon in the mouth.
Okay.
Is that just white people?
Shit.
By Eaton and Sandhurst and well
connected by his Swiss family fought
tooth and it's not about talent address.
Many people love you.
I love how she's like ranting at him.
It was asked to be included in this bowl
and he just made a tweet joking about it
and now all of a sudden like he,
he's getting shit for this poll where
people made a popular vote that they
would like to see him in it
almost more than you do yourself,
but please can someone on your team come
up with that own ideas or that own
material?
Must we perpetually crowbar in gender
and color where it doesn't fit our
imagination.
It wasn't his idea.
First of all.
And second.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like she's the one crow barring in
race isn't a part of James Bond.
He's just a guy.
He's despised the coolest spot.
The fact that he's black is incidental
and he's British by the way.
He's got a cool slick ash British accent
when I think James Bond British is what
I think,
right?
Not Black or white or whatever.
He's a British spy.
He's got a dope accent.
That sounds cool.
He fucks like crazy.
He's a bad ass spy.
And you look down the,
you know that white snipey?
Yeah.
The sniper.
Can we stop making everything about
race?
It's like no one was sounds good to me,
man.
Thing the way we love these characters
maters as evidenced by the outrage.
When someone attempts to mess with the
things we love.
So you see address.
It's not about your color or you.
It's about bond.
James Bond.
How dare she say that?
I love what you're directing it towards
him.
He's like,
what the fuck did I do as an actor?
It's some other thoughts,
but it's already been a long something
about it.
You know?
I disagree.
I think you'd be great and I hope he
gets it and I'd like to see what going
to do about it.
You will not be James Bond.
I like to see what you're going to do
about it.
Lady.
Going to find the footage and just
destroy it.
Sounds like a threat does.
I love this.
I love the term.
Gentlemen of Color.
Why do you.
Why do you have to put it like that?
Just say black dude.
It sounds less weird.
He's a gentleman of color.
Have you met my friend Tony?
Be like,
what?
That's weird,
dude.
Don't say that.
Oh,
the black guy,
excuse me.
They prefer gentlemen of color now.
Okay.
Evidenced by the outrage.
When someone attempts to mess with the
things we love.
So you see dress.
It's not about please don't attempt to
thing and to mess with the things I
love,
which is being white.
Okay.
How'd I do?
Did I get through that?
You need a writing up there every why?
Yeah.
Guys,
listen,
that's just my opinion.
I don't think James Bond needs to be
white.
Oh,
she was saying,
wait,
where do I saw this one video of someone
saying that it was like as if a white
person played a black role.
What was that?
I didn't see that clip or what?
What did I see that Dan?
I remember that too.
It cracked me up.
I was just thinking the last,
a little chunk of that.
Did you finish out that there was this
great clip that just had me rolling
where she was like,
what did I miss?
She says like,
no,
that's like having a a what?
That's like having a white person play
coon to Kente from roots.
That's about race.
Whereas explicitly about.
It's not the same.
Get dumbed down.
Let me try to find it.
I don't want to watch this video 20
times though.
A short
Da.
We watched this short one on twitter.
All right,
let's finish this.
Fuck.
Damn.
We watched the wrong one.
How could this happen?
Why did this happen?
Oh Man.
All right.
Let's pick up from here.
The Cold War era,
and that's the glory of the thing.
A throwback because James Bond isn't.
He's written as an upper class,
are really good white top form with a
silver well connected to play Winnie
Mandela.
How would the bender and color where it
doesn't fit and how come it doesn't work
the other way?
If I was to play Winnie Mandela,
how would that go down?
She's accounting.
I don't know.
Why would you even.
Why would you want to play?
Man?
I didn't know what she's talking about.
It looks like she's like,
what if I played a black slave?
How would that go down?
Pretty bad because it's about race.
James Bond has nothing to do about race
and power and identity and she's talking
about the wife of Nelson Mandela,
so it's like explicitly about apartheid.
It's a fictional character that's a real
person that's black about apartheid.
And what if I played Hitler and a film,
I think I would have said a lot of white
supremacists and that's just not right.
Frankly.
I'm seeing as a cow what's the issue and
if they cost money and I can watch her
anymore.
Oh,
white shaft,
bitch.
Shut the fuck up.
Shaft was a film.
I don't need to Belabor this anymore.
I think we get it right.
I played the wrong one.
I would like to see.
Uh,
would you watch white shaft dealer?
I actually don't know.
I don't know if everything.
Chef,
what is the chef?
Sick.
Let's move on.
Grand jury.
Oh God.
Not this one.
We can skip because there was a lot of
stuff.
Grand jury report.
No.
Ila.
Our duty is to report the news.
We are here to report current events and
news and culture and to tell you guys
how to think and feel.
Grand jury report,
Catholic priests ran a child porn ring
and six Pittsburgh basically throughout
Pennsylvania.
This,
this is shocking to me.
I guess.
Let's start with this video.
This is horrifying.
Wait,
is this it here?
Yeah.
Now this is.
This is just plain evil.
I mean,
I don't really know what.
How else would you describe this and
Pennsylvania?
There is an epidemic,
an actual pedophile ring.
Okay.
I've just 300 priests.
I don't know how many priests are in
Pennsylvania,
but I can't imagine more than like a
thousand.
I mean,
I don't know what's the number but what
does that.
What does that 30 percent.
That's a whole state and it just.
It kinda pisses me off because you're
seeing a lot of people.
All these conspiracy theories about like
satanic pedophile rings like this q and
on and pizza gate and all this shit.
Alex Jones goes off.
He says the world is run by pedophiles,
Bro.
Look at your own fucking church.
This is the most evil shit I've ever
heard in my life.
Yeah.
How can you talk about pizza gate when
the Catholic church is literally a safe,
Tannic Colt?
When you have 300 priests systematically
abusing kids and Pennsylvania,
everybody in that organization knows
it's happening.
Everybody,
the priests,
the that's part of the story is that
they were covering up flat.
How are they?
I and I'm,
am I supposed to believe that they're
not all participating?
How can you let that evilness slide in
the church like their whole thing is
community and serving God and like,
and so how am I supposed to believe that
over the course of many decades,
you can have that many pedophile
priests.
You're covering up and you're moving
them around and you're not all in on it.
Not just covering it up.
Who is all in on it?
Everybody.
What do you mean everybody?
If 30 percent of the people that work
for you or fucking kids,
like what?
What?
What reason do you have to keep that
system moving?
If you find a pedophile,
you kick come out and you'll apologize.
When you have 300 and you're covering
up,
you're perpetuating a system that you
probably want to keep going.
I think there's a lot more of these guys
fucking kids than just the 300 and it's
just so funny and ironic to me that
people will go slander and end date,
say dangerous shit like pizza gate and
um,
basically make up stuff and on and all
this shit.
Say Obama is a pedophile when you have
this like an and the shit that you're
going to hear is going to make your
sprinkler.
I mean this is really evil stuff.
So just prepare for them.
And this is shocking.
Do I sound like a conspiracy theorist?
But I'm basing it on something.
Well,
I'm not sure.
What are you?
Everybody's in on it.
Nobody.
The fucking.
Everybody.
The whole church.
Not the,
not the people,
not the congregation,
but like all the priests,
the bishops know the pope,
the pope.
People were saying,
what was the last pope the resigned that
never happened.
People speculate that he was fucking
kids and he didn't want it to come out.
Imagine the pope is raping children and
you're talking about pizza gate.
What do you really see?
That it makes me think I do really care
about kids,
or is it just a political attack?
Yeah,
dude,
this shit is so upset about child sex
abuse by
priests.
It found credible allegations exist
against more than 300 priests and that
more than 1000 child victims were
identifiable.
What is worse because of lost records or
fear of coming forward,
it is likely the true number of victims
is deep into the thousands of Jean
[inaudible] has been working on this for
us and gene.
Tens of thousands more massive
investigation.
Yeah,
and it was with countless numbers of law
enforcement,
prosecutors,
other attorneys within the office of the
attorney general,
and of course the grand jurors officials
are saying that this report is the
largest,
most comprehensive document into child
sexual abuse within the Catholic Church
that has ever been produced in the
United States.
This report took two years.
It was written by 23 Pennsylvania Grand
Jurors who listened to dozens of witness
testimonies and witnesses.
You're studying documents about alleged
child sex abuse in six dioceses,
which involved 54 of Pennsylvania,
67 counties.
The report states that the testimony was
heard from dozens of witnesses and half
a million pages of internal documents
were subpoenaed.
It also states that they were credible
allegations found against over 300
priests.
Over 1000 child victims were
identifiable,
but it's believed that the true numbers
are way more,
way more to the victims were boys,
but girls were also victims.
Some routines,
some are younger,
some were manipulated with alcohol or
pornography.
They were raped in various forms and
fashions and grand jurors found the
church leaders in every part of the
state preferred to protect the abusers
and their institution above everything
else,
every part of the state,
every part of the institution,
every single time that's a church policy
to protect the institution at the cost
of the abusers,
perpetuating a system.
It's basically.
What exactly does the Catholic Church do
at separate kids?
I mean,
what exactly would you say you do?
Catholic church.
Are you enjoying that tax exemption?
I'm,
I mean,
I'm disgusted.
I'm repulsed.
Like I think it's time to close it down.
I think it's time to lock shop up on
that church.
Imagine any other.
Fucking.
I mean,
I'm really upset,
imagined scientology.
I mean,
which I fuck.
Imagine eyes.
Imagine any organized religion being
like,
Oh yeah,
sorry,
we raped all your kids.
You need to imagine what scientology.
Yeah,
but I'm saying if imagined this scope of
like all the kids are being raped and
scientology.
Yeah.
Watch day.
Any serious bad example?
Imagine.
Yeah.
Okay.
Example,
they're are all fucked up,
but what exactly do they do there?
Why are we giving them a tax exemption?
Okay,
this is evil.
You guys.
This is just actual evil.
It's like like all the weird
conspiracies you hear about pizza gate
and like weird child sex torture and
pain.
Basements is happening in the Catholic
church.
I like to hear this because the coverup.
What's most important goal
these petitioners
is Alex Jones ranting about this.
I don't know.
Maybe he is.
I hope he is.
That'd be pretty weird.
If he wasn't.
I didn't know how you can bring up pizza
or cuing on and not this all day.
I'm now.
You can't talk about this all day if you
care about pedophilia,
and for a time some of the diocese
sought to prevent the entire report from
ever seeing the light of day.
In effect,
they wanted to cover up the cover up.
They sought to do the same thing that
senior church leaders in the diocese we
investigated have done for decades,
burry the sexual abuse by priests upon
children and cover it up forever.
The report states that because of the
cup,
okay,
I'll let me.
Almost all of the abuse is too old to be
prosecuted.
The Orange has issued present moments
against two priests who was out of the
300,
300.
They're only,
they covered it up for so long that
these guys have passed the statute of
limitation and can no longer be charged
extra for two.
I mean,
that's a criminal organization that
knows what it's doing.
Folks.
Right?
Round of applause to these guys.
Let's give them tax exemption.
Let's make sure they never have to pay
taxes.
Um,
it gets crazier here.
I'm going to read some facts here.
I've got about this.
This is a quote from one of the victims,
George claims that the priest began
taking photos of him on a camera.
All the priest giggled,
so there's many priests involved in this
one location.
Then added photos of him to a collection
of other teen boys.
According to the grand jury,
these men and another priest who were
part of a ring of predatory priests that
raped children,
shared intelligence of potential victims
and manufacturer child pornography and
parishes and rectories.
This group of priests used whips,
violence and sadism and raping their
victims reads one line and nearly 900
pages of documents.
Hello.
Is the whole world talking about this?
I mean,
I know people are talking about it,
but Dan just looked.
He said nothing on info wars about it.
I mean the stories a couple of days old,
but like,
hello.
This is kind of insane you guys.
Yeah,
and this isn't just the United States.
There's crazy in Argentina and Ireland.
This,
I mean there was huge stories about
child abuse.
It's like pedophiles are literally just
joining the organization.
We shocked sadism,
whips and violence and sadism and
raping,
systematic raping.
What I wonder if I'm religious people
after hearing this would still send
their kids do whatever it is they're
sending them to.
I don't know.
It's a good question.
It's the Catholic Church.
I mean the Catholic Church.
The pope,
right?
Where does the buck stop?
Who's taken responsibility for this?
Are we as a society taking
responsibility for this that our kids
and our citizens and our fellow,
our fellow citizens,
our children are being raped and the
guys who did it are being covered up for
so long that they can't even be charged.
These guys are chilling dude there at
our local parks and I'm not and I'm not
and I'm being serious sin.
What was the.
What was I saying earlier?
Serious as what?
As a school shooting.
I forgot what it was.
Thank you.
Dan.
This world is so fucked you guys.
Why are we not pizza gate?
We have so if you imagine being this
fucked there,
there was a email about a handkerchief
with a pizza and upside down.
It looks like a pedophile.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Let me read this again.
The group of priests use whips,
violence and sadism and ripe raping
their victims,
but at the the handkerchief upside down,
why aren't you talking about this
genius?
You don't need any more fucking
evidence.
My skin is crawling and there's more in
the details of what they've done is.
It's horrible.
It's just horrible to read.
The report said that meant here.
This is.
This is so fucked.
If you could top sadism,
I mean this is part of the sales
reports,
said that the priests gave a specific
gift to children.
They favored something they
could wear that would mark them as prime
targets for abuse.
He said,
they told me that they,
the priests would give their boys their
altar boys or their favorite boys.
These crosses.
He.
George told the grand jury,
so he gave me a big gold cross to where
that Mark Timm,
so all the other priest knew he was
fair.
Game for abuse.
Can I get another?
Look at that handkerchief.
There's no need for conspiracy as guys.
This is as fucked as anything.
Your imagination can comprehend.
Almost every instance of abuse we found
is too old to be prosecuted.
Here's some more highlights and
greenboro priests impregnated a 17 year
old girl,
fortunate pasture signature on a
marriage certificate and divorced the
girl months later,
another precinct,
Greensboro groomed middle school
students for sex according to the grand
jury by telling them that Mary had to
bite off the cord and the lick Jesus
clean after the activity.
Well,
what does q and have to say about the
fuck?
Well,
nevermind this.
I can't wait to see what,
what,
what?
Obama and George Bush and Bill Clinton
and Hillary Clinton.
Let's hear more about their sex ring and
Harrisburg.
A priest abused five sisters from the
same family and collected samples of the
urine,
pubic hair and menstrual blood.
This is like you've seen that show,
true detectives.
How it's like so sick and twisted beyond
imagination.
This is real.
Nothing.
Yet.
You know the.
The phrase stranger than fiction can't
make this shit up and Harrisburg.
A priests raped a seven year old girl
who was in a hospital after her tonsils
were removed and Pittsburgh.
This.
This is just the highlights that they
got,
and this is just one state,
one area,
and Pittsburgh Church church officials
said that a 15 year old boy pursued and
literally seduced a priest,
church officials.
That was their statement and the fence
of the priest that a 15 year old boy
pursued and literally seduced a priests.
Well,
I guess that clears that up.
A church report later acknowledged that
the priest had admitted to Sado
masochistic activities with several
boys.
Are you sick yet?
Yes.
I feel that people about this.
Everyone's just like,
oh man,
there it goes to Catholic church again.
I'm ready to lock it up.
I don't think these guys,
their library card is being revoked.
What's going on?
This is the most evil shit I've read,
and allentown a preset admitted sexually
molesting a boy and pleaded for help
according to documents,
but was left in ministry for several
more years.
Priest rapes a child.
He begs for help and they leave them
there for several more years.
Hmm.
It's just,
it's so horrible.
And so how do you.
Even when you even say
what I want to see action,
because we've been talking about this
shit for like decades and it's just
getting worse and worse here.
This is a wonderful one.
And Alan's town,
a priests who had abused several boys.
According to the grand jury,
was given a recommendation to work at
Disney world by the church.
They conveniently left out the part
where he was a convicted a child rapist.
Would this priest be good?
Uh,
can we get a reference for his job at
Disneyland?
He's going to be in a mickey mouse
outfit,
taking photos with kids.
Great Guy.
Loves kids.
Really?
Really loves kids.
Great with kids.
Highly recommend.
Well,
and he wasn't convicted,
right?
None of these guys.
Well,
the church knew,
right?
No,
no,
no.
That's too old,
right?
And Scranton.
Isn't that where the office is?
Sure.
Is the electric city a pre?
Oh,
like God.
A praise to was later.
Serve prison time for abusing children
was found to have been HIV positive for
years.
Like he would fucking care.
According to CBS,
uh,
Pennsylvania grand jury report
investigating the matter of states,
the church officials gave a former
priest a positive reference to work at
Disneyland,
even though officials field at at least
one allegation about a sexual abusing a
boy.
The report says he worked at the theme
park for 18 years,
driving the train to the magic kingdom.
Well,
isn't that a nice,
a little analogy.
Pretty creepy.
All aboard the ride to the magic
kingdom.
His favorite ride.
Peter Pan.
Oof.
Boys never grow up.
Thanks.
You know,
this reminds me when I was a kid in my
neighborhood that was like a religious
neighbor that um,
I guess they had like a,
I don't know what you call it,
where you go to classes when they teach
you there,
they talk about the Torah and they teach
you.
So like on Saturdays they would tell all
the kids in the neighborhood to come and
do they give a popsicles?
Sorry.
I remember wanting to go and my dad was
like,
he knows something was up.
You're not going to this stuff.
Because like now that I think about it,
it's pretty weird.
Why are you inviting kids and giving
them pups?
Cool.
Why do you want all the kids over there?
Yeah.
With like this irresistible invitation.
Oh yeah.
It's so easy to be deviously hide behind
religion.
That was really slick of your dad by the
way.
Yeah.
I wonder if people knew or if he just
had the insight or if he had.
It's very paranoid about this stuff and
for a good rhythm.
I mean it's.
It's so ironic obviously that like under
the guise of God and this whole
institution of Christ is the most evil,
evil,
evil shit.
We all agree and this society,
everybody agrees like child rapists are
like the worst.
Right?
We all agree.
Hmm.
Somehow.
I mean at this point,
if you give your church,
if you give your kid over to the church,
I mean,
you're pretty much taking a crap shoot.
Pretty much.
There's like a really good chance
they're going to get molested.
Fuck that shit.
Really.
I don't know,
man.
It just pisses me off because there's
all of these stupid fucking conspiracies
that are ruined it with like so little
evidence that it's.
There's no evidence it took a total
conspiracy that are fucking with people
that have nothing to do with this shit
and they're ignoring.
It's making a joke of this serious
actual or they're just using it as
political attack and it's can't be more
obvious than this because they're not
talking about the church,
but somehow Obama's pedophile,
Hillary Clinton's a pedophile.
Okay.
It's shocking,
man.
It's so evil,
so fucking evil.
How can you allow organization that's
covered up that treachery,
that evilness for so long?
It continued to exist.
They should be ran out.
I really wonder,
what did the normal people think like
actual religious people.
I would like to know,
can we get calls of Catholics
like you got to assume that you're
oppressed is most likely
a pedophile.
I'm really curious what people are going
to think mean.
Everybody's covering it up at,
uh,
what's the,
what's the number?
Eight.
Oh,
eight.
Dan hotmail.
Eight hot meme.
Which seems if there's any Catholics
listening,
I'm going to clear the call queue.
If you're on the.
If you're.
If you've been holding.
Sorry guys.
You're getting hung up on.
Deal with it.
If there's a Catholic listening that has
a strong opinion about this,
give me a call.
I'm interested in people that disagree
with me.
I want to hear how you think I'm wrong
about the church this week.
We with what they know.
Well,
I'm saying like close it down.
So is it not as bad as.
I mean it seems like unarguably bad,
but either way I want to know what
Catholics think about this.
So meanwhile as we populate some,
cause we've got the casting thing that I
don't really care about honestly.
And then we've got the this I do like
Kevin Spacey,
Billionaire Boys Club movie came out and
it earned $126 on opening day was a
limited release who was on like 10
theaters but still okay with $126.
That's like 10 people.
It's actually less probably.
That's just friends and family.
That's not even friends and family.
There was like thousands of people
involved in that movie.
Probably 126 bucks.
Shit,
you could make that work in that.
Damn.
That's fucked up.
That one person can fuck up at home
project,
you know,
for everyone involved.
Apparently it was a really awful movie
though.
I saw in rotten tomatoes they had like
five percent or something.
So I mean the name billionaire boys club
get a better name.
That's got to be embarrassing though.
You should have.
I'm not going to say it.
I was going to make a joke.
It's probably inappropriate.
As inappropriate as raping kids as a
priest though.
No,
I feel like I should get a little more
leeway on things.
Uh,
well I am,
has been a longtime February of the
podcast at the podcast of the shell of
HDHP productions.
We've,
I've enjoyed Williams antics because
he's,
as far as I,
I mean he's musically talented,
I guess not my style,
but he's very socially challenged and,
and he thinks he's very suave.
He wants to be Kanye.
He thinks he's Kanye.
I think you're right.
He is Kanye.
But I am afraid he might be Kanye,
but without the Yay.
He's more of like straight up con now
that I dunno,
I dunno,
I'm not gonna.
Call him a calm,
but he's definitely a goofball.
Just kidding.
So by my to the joy of this rabbit hole,
we're going to go down right now.
Is that I this video?
And then I found out that there's
actually a subreddit dedicated called
cringe.
I am.
I was like,
wow,
this guy's prolific cringe or if he's
got his own subreddit shit.
Well let's start with this video.
You'll tell me if you think this is
interesting.
No,
I know.
Just can't decide.
Does not mean the folks that go home,
we don't figure out how we work
together.
Um,
so this is for the show and what I think
will be great for the finals has nothing
to do with how I feel about you being an
artist moving forward.
So that name is that name.
They're running at a time.
Really running out of time.
Hold on.
Wait,
I'm gonna let Jennifer.
I know it's tough.
Well,
let's have a name.
that's really enough.
It's going to be going to be
okay.
Got It.
This is the hardest thing.
Get on with it much to this show.
And then when he says it,
nobody cares.
I just want them to stop the music.
Tanya,
kind of a goofy and not that bad,
but like it really more about the fact
that there's a cringe I am subreddit.
And so then I hopped on over there and I
was like,
wow,
there is some good stuff here.
So kind of want to go down the list of
cringe.
I am top of all time and now this one is
really pointed.
I would say it's very educational and
maintenance.
Were you a little bit as well?
Startup of the year guide,
tip of the week.
What makes a great logo?
First off your logo has to be just as
impactful in black and white.
Kind of reminds me of that kid is like,
you will.
You were,
you got you got my dream is do you
sure if your logo is not?
I mean then there's a problem.
He has like his.
I know very,
very slick.
His eyes or he can't make eye contact
and he started on drugs or something
collapses.
When you blow it up really,
really big,
then there's a problem.
If your logo can't transform itself to
other things and you still know what
that logo is and there's a problem,
so you should be able to have all those
things.
What are they doing in the there two
cameras and have a camera there and he's
looking through that camera.
They're not using the character but he's
not supposed to.
I don't think it's supposed to switch
companies is not supposed to dark
between the cameras.
Now they show it when it's not like no,
but you're not supposed to dark between
the cameras.
They just wanted like a nice profile
shot and he's doing this.
He's doing like this,
but I put that he's supposed to do with
that.
He's looking kind of in between them
though.
The company's objective on a symbolic
level.
Right?
Because you have to think of what India
is going to do to the world.
Right?
We know it's silicone valley did to the
world with him.
We know China does for the world,
but what India is going to do for the
world is they're going to create this
symbolic language because India is
unique because they speak English.
He's talking about about logo.
Yeah,
he's talking about the logo,
different alphabet.
Damn,
he's on.
He's on.
He's on to something.
I wonder what.
I wonder how he wipes easier read
jamming or what was the green?
Jasmine Green.
A Green Gentlemen.
So I don't want to pick up a red jacket.
Going to add a whole new type of visual
connecting language to the planning and
symbology and logos are going to play a
big role on that.
Understanding something just by looking
at a logo or different symbols,
a new language,
a new type of font.
I can talk and talk about it.
It doesn't say anything.
Well,
it's.
It's really that,
that ultimate saying all you need in
life to be successful is confidence and
ignorance.
It's like if you have that unshakeable
confidence,
if you don't even think about anything
you're saying you never consider what
you're saying.
You're going to sound to some people.
Smart.
Anyway.
Do we have any callers?
Let's see.
Looks like we got one.
What's his name and what do you think?
Is this a call?
You're saying he's got one on deck that
he thinks will be better,
so maybe hold off for a second.
Okay guys.
Well we've pretty much reached the end,
but I want to take this call.
I'm canceling cable.
I'm so sick of fucking cable.
Me and Isla were let you know what?
Let's get cable.
We got it for the first time ever,
like a few months ago and it's so
stupid.
Well we said,
you know what?
People like cable,
let's try it out.
It was almost nostalgic for me because I
used.
I remember like my parents are there.
Could you just turn on the TV and
something that will play.
Like you don't have to choose all the
time.
Right.
What to watch with Netflix and those
kind of services,
but oh my God,
it's just commercial.
Well first of all it costs like $120 a
month.
Okay.
Which is more than double.
Pretty much what it would cost that
every streaming app,
including like Hbo and Showtime
[inaudible].
So then there are so many commercials,
like the other day I sit down for
breakfast and it's at the tail end of
the show and I'm sitting,
I'm eating and I'm just watching
commercials and it's like five minutes
long by the time I'm done with my
breakfast,
the shows back on.
And then let's say you don't like the
show.
You waited five minutes to see what it's
about.
Then you're wanting to switch the
channel.
Yeah,
always it turns on on commercials and
then it's like a knight of fire.
If you just go channel up through all
the main channels,
you're gonna hit commercials about 50
percent of the time.
The other 50 percent of the time you
were about to go onto a commercial?
Yeah.
Like I can watch the same shows on Hulu
without commercials.
Why am I on cable?
Why do I have cable?
I don't get it.
The only thing is that you can record
shows,
but I mean they never invented that
dude.
But like,
and then the other day our recording
thing wasn't working and it's not
recording the shows we want.
And I'm like,
okay,
so there really is no reason to have
this.
Then the shit that's on their flip flop
flip and flop.
Pawn stars flip or flop.
It's like the dumbest shit that you
didn't even know existed.
Like I'm happier knowing that these
shows don't exist.
There's so many house flipping shows.
Do we need more house flipping shows?
You've got a gay couple.
You got a black couple that a white
couple.
You've got one Asian,
one red had a couple.
You've got a couple of that's divorced.
They're in Las Vegas.
They're in California.
They're in Houston or in Florida or the
lottery.
The lottery.
That was one of definitely talked about
this before we talked about it.
I don't.
I believe these shows that exist.
There's a show on home on this.
Oh,
you must've talked about it.
There's one called my lottery dream
house where they get lottery winners and
follow them to build their dream house
with the lottery winnings.
I'm like,
how niche do you get?
There's so many news.
Twenty four hour news all day every day.
So News.
So many people with opinions.
So many commercials.
What am I missing?
Hmm,
what am I missing?
Why do people like cable?
Do we have a call yet?
I'm just dragging on trying to waste
time.
We're good on that.
It's been two hours.
Okay.
Gabrielle here.
Hero.
Is this a go and right?
Gabriela?
That's the one.
All right,
let's bring her in.
Gabriela.
Thanks for giving us a ring.
No problem.
So tell me about.
So okay.
You,
you've been listening to our
conversation about the Catholic church.
I have.
Yeah.
So what's your reaction to what I've
been saying?
Um,
a lot of reactions.
So it's very interesting.
I went to 12 years of Catholic school
and I'm still a practicing Catholic.
Um,
my personal reaction is usually to just
disconnect myself a little bit from kind
of what's going on in the Catholic
Church and just,
I still go to mass.
So it kind of worked a disconnect.
That piece of it just to the priests,
the people,
the institution itself.
Um,
because then it kinda gets a little bit
culty and weird.
Um,
but for me,
since I grew up going to church,
there's something calming about it.
But you really have to work to remove
yourself from what's going on because it
gets down to like telling the priest
will tell you how to vote and what you
should believe,
what stickley and you know,
there's a lot of things that I don't
agree with with the Catholic church,
but I still practice and I still believe
in the fundamentals of it.
So as far as all the best.
Yeah.
Good.
I was just gonna say it.
Was there anything that I said that
upset you?
No,
I think that I think that the sex
scandals have been going on since I been
very young.
Um,
and part of the way that the Catholic
Church works is that there the priests
move around from congregation to
congregation before the sex scandal
started or maybe because they started,
um,
but they move around from congregation
to congregation to kind of mirror how
the apostles moved around in preached.
So it's a way of covering it up was,
oh,
this is moving to a different
congregation when in reality I'm
originally from Long Island,
New York,
or they would move them to upstate New
York.
So they would all be in one facility and
then that's when the coverup would
happen.
Um,
so my high school was actually,
they just closed it down,
um,
and one of the bishops from that whole
Pennsylvania scandal is actually coming
to long island now.
So it's been in the news quite a bit for
us.
Um,
so it's just,
I don't even the cover up on some of
this stuff.
I don't know if you folks are into,
um,
some of those netflix series that go
into some of the crimes,
but there's one called the book about a
cover up of a non in Baltimore where
people were killed and shit.
Yep.
And I have friends that went to that
church and knew that priests and their
reaction to kind of the whole thing.
It's just because the whole,
the whole cover up when he was beyond
the Catholic Church and into,
if you have Catholics in the police
force that it,
you know,
just
gotten so out of control.
So.
And,
but you,
you sound sympathetic to what I'm
saying.
You don't seem to have much conflict
with my claims.
No.
So it's a,
it sounds very cool to you though,
the way you're describing it is like
we've got Catholics in the police force,
you've got them all over the place.
They're all covering up.
I mean it sounds very cold,
like.
Yeah,
it is.
I mean if you talked to like some of my
family that's very catholic very badly.
Well,
what do your parents think about it?
Because they're probably more old
school.
Like I want to know what's the
dissenting opinion because I'm sitting
here saying,
shut down the Catholic church.
I want to hear someone be like,
I want to hear somebody say that's
you're fucked.
That's fucked up for saying that.
Yeah.
I mean I would disagree with that,
right?
Like I wouldn't want the Catholic Church
shut down.
I would want to see some of the priests
that were molesting children go to jail.
I think that it's,
you're not above the law,
you know what I mean?
But don't.
But if you talked to what I'm sorry.
I mean,
um,
if you talk to.
Let's go ahead.
I got my,
I don't know.
So you talked to like my Stepdad,
he's very conservative.
It's kind of like it's all over now.
It's all over,
isn't happening anymore.
It's all over now.
Kinda in denial about it.
They think it was a past problem that
people are still digging up dirt.
Yup.
It's like if you're.
I'm assuming you don't have kids right
now,
right?
I don't,
but I have a nephew that was just
baptized.
Are you worried about your nephew being
around priest?
I mean I feel like you have to be
careful with it,
right?
Like the Catholic schooling is a lot
different now because there are a lot
less nuns and priests period,
which means that there's a lot of lay
people that are teaching those classes.
There's not really a heavy presence of
priests.
Like yes you go to school it on when
you're in the service of like doing the
office serving and the things like that
that it seems a little bit more intense.
Sketchy.
But I did.
I did date one person that anytime it
was brought up but like fly off the
handle.
So you know that something happened and
something like not great.
So what were the results like?
The longterm was also that,
you know,
even if you go to therapy to deal with
it,
I was still there.
It's like any sort of abuse,
abuse as abuse,
it doesn't matter.
You sound,
sound sympathetic and um,
yeah.
So,
well thanks for sharing your story with
us.
Well,
frankly,
I,
I mean the truth is if you have an
instant,
I,
I'm,
I don't want to get in an argument with
you specifically because you didn't call
to argue with me,
so that's fine.
But like if you have an instance,
you say you don't shut down the church.
Well first of all,
constitutionally you can't shut down to
church anyway.
But it's like if you have systematic
cover up,
I feel like the institution has proven
that it can be.
Why does it exist?
Why does it exist at all anyway?
We don't have to.
I'm not trying to argue with you,
but thank you for calling God bless you.
Appreciate Jugs and uh,
wish you all the best I got.
I'm not looking for people that agree
with me for Christ's sake.
Okay.
Well,
I think,
you know,
most rational people would
have a hard time district.
Well,
I feel like what I'm saying is fucked up
in a way because everybody outside all
over the world and being like,
shut down the Catholic church.
So I'm trying to understand why what I'm
saying is fucked up.
Well,
I think the,
the one point she made that was
interesting and it's probably true for
most is that because you know,
that this particular story is about
instances that happened in the past.
I think a lot of people would probably
think,
oh,
we,
we clean this up.
It's not like this anymore.
You know what I mean?
Um,
which may or may not be true.
I don't know.
But that's probably how they rationalize
it.
Hmm.
It's hard to know.
It's tricky.
It's really tricky.
Got To be careful on there when do your
kids.
But isn't that fucked up the first
someone who's an active member of the
church to be like,
you gotta be careful.
Whatever.
Alright.
I've said my piece about it.
So disturbing story,
shreddies gone nuts.
Starting to shred cables here.
So guys,
thanks for listening.
Hope you enjoyed this Tuesday episode.
This is the.
Let me tell you what to think and feel
episode.
Those are the Tuesday episodes,
the right opinion episodes.
Remember guys,
there's not much time left on these
represent shirts.
You got an in black,
you got an entire night,
you got a Hoodie,
you got the extra thick hat on like four
days left or not even less,
right Dan?
Yeah,
I think it ends Friday at noon.
So yeah,
about three days.
And make sure to gut it.
Teddy fresh.com/collection/sale.
That's happened.
Mouthful.
You'll figure it out.
Having a 50 percent off sale.
That's insane.
And how do we do to release some new
items finally?
Pretty soon.
In about two weeks.
Oh yeah.
We're going to make a video.
Kind of a preview for Ethan and yella
before.
Maybe not.
Maybe.
Definitely.
I'm excited.
You don't want to.
I just say maybe because we haven't
posted in so long.
I don't even.
It's like a blog that would just be like
a Bot.
How do we do?
How is this episode was good?
Emotional rollercoaster,
like you said,
I always feel like an asshole,
like expressing strong opinions.
What is the.
This is the.
This is the strong offended therapist
while you watch the show and I will be
spending a lot of time on.
I'm better help.
I need so much time on better home.
It was fine.
It was good.
You see how fucked up I am you guys.
I'm having a dialogue on.
On camera.
Will you just do this off camera?
I usually shop for Cameron.
Be like.
Was that okay?
You guys.
Was that show?
Okay.
Roll up and go.
I want you guys to see just how insecure
and how neurotic and anxious who a
person I am on camera,
because that's what this podcast is
about.
People say,
you know,
look,
now he's chewing on.
That is so cute.
You're so fucking cute luck.
You can say I'm an asshole.
You can say I'm a Jew.
When you says an insult,
that's not okay.
That's true.
You can say whatever you want about me,
but I feel like
this is as real as it gets.
This is live,
baby.
There's no take backs.
I might sound like an asshole.
I might sound like an idiot.
I might sound uneducated,
might sound racist,
but this is as real as it gets.
There's no take backs.
This is live.
Okay,
so forgive me if sometimes I sound
stupid or offensive or you think.
I mean,
there's no editing it out.
It's all off the cuff.
This is live.
This is who I am,
just like garth brooks said,
and that's just who I am.
There's no hiding from me when it's live
me for myself,
when there's no hiding from it,
there's no hiding from myself when it's
live.
And so I want you guys to see how
neurotic and insecure and anxious I am
because the truth is,
you guys probably think I'm a perfect
cool ass dude.
They just confident always.
All right,
just fucking good.
Cheering on your shoe.
Now what is a trump?
But the truth is,
boy,
don't feel like that guy ever and think
is important for you to know that.
Right?
Yeah.
Alright.
Only soundboard I need is to get on my.
Shut my ass down.
Alright.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
Please let us know if you did or didn't
really want to know if they didn't.
I mean if everyone's like,
I didn't enjoy that,
that I should probably.
Listen.
Dan will filter comments to me.
That's how insecure and fragile I am.
I don't,
I can't.
I literally can't even see it.
That's how fragile I am.
You Bet.
I want you to know I am a fragile.
I am petty.
I'm insecure and I'm deeply unhappy.
What you do.
I brought in the,
uh,
the podcast theme song,
which is very upbeat as you're playing
right now.
So I'm just gonna remember that guys.
I'm not A.
I'm fucked.
Probably more than you are not a Dick
measuring contest.
I wasn't going to say have a nice
weekend.
Not a weekend and weekend.
That's what I'm saying.
But this Friday we've gotten Bert
Kreischer,
which I'm excited about.
Super Funny.
He's super great guy.
We finally get them in the podcast.
He's one of my favorite comedians and
hilarious and shirtless.
I wonder if he's going to wear a shirt.
That's a good question.
Actually.
I prefer shirt speaking frankly,
but I leave the choice to end.
I think he wears a chef probably eight a
day.
He shared it,
so tune in on Friday at our usual time.
I hope you guys enjoyed this and you've
been filled in with the right up in.
Thanks for watching.